netflix reported record profits for the
past year
they've added 8.5 million new
subscribers
isn't that insane now that's in big part
to this popular trend of
gentle tv shows that's what they call
them yeah
netflix has these gentle shows like the
great british baking show
the great pottery throwdown well netflix
has seen such a huge increase in demand
for these types of shows
they're releasing an entire new block of
them
yeah they're they're pretty cool check
it out
from the people who brought you the
great british baking show comes a new
slate of incredibly gentle tv
with shows like darn it australia's
quietest
sock making competition wagons being
pulled by children
blowing gently on hot soup with the
stars animal planet presents
calm herds fluffing up pillows to smooth
jazz
things getting dipped the ultimate
napkin folding champion
dateline murderers taking bubble baths
and
every bob ross episode played at once
netflix gentle tv because you're too
fragile to watch anything else right now
you